[Music]
new here tonight at 11 finding baby
formula has been a huge task for a lot
of families across the country including
right here in las vegas in fact a recent
study showed by the end of april 40
percent of top selling baby formulas
were out of stock that's up 11 percent
just since november victoria saha has a
look at one family's ordeal
as grandma mary randina fixes baby mia's
bottle she can't help but wonder when
and where the next can of formula will
come from hoping and praying that we're
going to continue to be able to hit the
store at the right time when they stock
the shelves randina says recently they
went into panic mode because mia's
parents only had one can of formula left
my husband and i were visiting my son in
california so we made him take us all
over
the city in san diego looking for it
couldn't find it in any of the stores
the shortage fueled by supply chain
issues and recent recalls is leaving
staff at local diaper banks like baby's
bounty feeling helpless it's a crisis
situation right now executive director
kelly maxwell says she's getting dozens
of calls from frantic parents every week
each day folks would come by picking up
a can two cans
and now we're nearly empty
some parents may resort to rationing the
formula but pediatrician dr keri uiji
sinha says that can turn deadly please
do not dilute it you can throw off your
child's electrolytes and in the end it
can result in brain swelling and the
child could sadly pass no matter which
brand you choose you need to follow the
serving suggestions to keep your baby
healthy now if you can't find the brand
that your baby needs doctors say you can
use generic store brands but only if
they're in the same category with
similar ingredients and you should also
know many retailers are limiting how
much formula you can buy right now